hello and welcome to this video with
that Kevin Rosa no no means I don't know
the guy good ol names oh here's a good
line a good line for white time I mean I
mean out of a black but that mean i
think bishop t to sm is stronger then 23
this is what's the is what it was this
is what i wanted to basically say sorry
okay so i have tried to be a little bit
annoying here with this pin and let's
seek a name can I keep this kind of pin
I mean it's not so easy for him to unpin
so maybe let's let's keep it for the
moment and see what is coming up with to
play with b5 it would be very ambitious
on my part probably also not very good
we'll see
not so easy for white because he has no
clear way to get rid of this pin yeah
Queen B 2 runs into Bishop e3 yeah this
is definitely definitely possible
question is where to go to see 602 g6
okay I'll go to c6 looks a little more
centralizing okay so if i take take on
d4 let's let's think about this whole
night with you can also play Bishop e3
in this position there should be three
hmm would be one night before it looks
very weird but I think I'm kind of kind
of intrigued by that idea I play night
before and then maybe beehive might be
completely bad to be honest
cubed maybe maybe still mmm that's
probably a good move
yeah that's a bit station in my pieces I
kind of stuck a little bit on yeah stuck
is wrong a kind of and some kind of yet
we had configuration let's see to maybe
he'll hmm let's see to I cannot take
unfortunately I mean I've pinned myself
if he takes with the king which seems
likely the screen to queen here right
what see Sam said better it's 90s
hanging may be here I'm not sure about
this takes takes I've got 25 at the end
this doesn't work and interesting
yeah yeah I've got a sub tech decks and
maybe night a 2 very cheeky move just
taking this night 195 I am not sure what
hmm ok he's not threatening that much I
think so let's play strengthening move
hmm Oh f7 is just hanging wow wow I was
an immensely stupid indecision Wow
what the heck
I am probably to fire home Wow very
sophisticated player so equal material
hooray I'm not losing straight away
that's good news time morning okay it's
a very hits a decent ending not sure if
that falls bastard
okay adds to it so very dry I didn't
expect this move but it's a way to not
draw I don't know from well I can take
this now right it's there something
wrong with taking I don't see it I just
took a bit too long have a deep one is
also quite quickly
check white resins yeah it's surprising
that I won the game at the end yeah in
the middle game I was certainly in
trouble I'm quite sure about this
playing this this way is was a bit
provocative here with keeping the pin
and so on quite the usual strategy that
I also recommended in my in my book was
to just go for some kind of Hedgehog put
the bishop on his heaven and so on at
them and this was certainly quite
provocative our computer doesn't give
white anything surprisingly now it wants
to play of six air probably this was a
bit nf6 now I assembly I simply
blundered this it just exactly what I
adjusted blunder and now he has to go 95
and is in excellent shape yak taking on
b5 was not necessary but he can still
play 95 and after this I'm probably okay
I guess o Queen c2 is a lot stronger now
interestingness keep this pin threatened
to this and keep this into gym yeah why
does this bed ahem no doubt engine gives
0.8 route d2 and possibly later 94 yeah
and he rats it's equal but somehow now
that you just blundered blundered into
it to this a six years to take first and
then a six this is a draw Austin this
kind of kind of thing yeah I just
blundered this I took a bit it took me a
bit long to take but I wasn't sure that
some kind of trickery going on yes
easeus just get the get the Queens of
the board i activate the king yeah it's
a fairly straightforward when yeah
that's a game that I shouldn't have
shouldn't have won from just judging
from the position I was in some trouble
down okay thanks for watching